welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the dark
thoughts brewing inside grogu's mind
and whether for the good of the galaxy
he should be put down like baby hitler
that's why you're such a little bastard
no one's ever changed you
hey happy new year i'm eric voss putting
grogoo on trial with me today is philip
molina happy new year buddy how ironic
is it that i did not know that this is
what we were gonna go over today and
this is the shirt that i got
literally in the mail right before we
start shooting
this is the shirt this is the same shirt
that
john is going to be really mad at me for
wearing in front of the blue screen
because we're never supposed to wear
blue in front of the floor
i think the actual color there is blue
dungeon blue it is
i made sure it was just just so they can
have fun try keying this suckers
although grogoo's height chart is on
mustafar
how embarrassing john is gonna be mad at
me i'm sorry well
maybe one of our new year's resolutions
could be making sure
our new rockstars merch shirts that
we're wearing on camera are
of the black or the white or the red
variety we have lots of great options
coming ahead in 2021
i'm really excited to see so resolve to
support us via our merch how about that
real quick sorry to kill your merch plug
i'm writing a movie about baby hitler oh
good
someone needs to cover that story well
everyone really wants to understand the
man behind
no it's it's not at all that it's
actually it's a comedy but still is it
just
extending out from deadpool 2's post
credit scene it's not
unrelated oh oh that's exciting speaking
of evil babies is grogu
evil we saw him toy around we've seen
him do some damage
and we've seen him like get off on it
we've seen grow grew
maim torture kill and roofie
[Music]
but to answer your question philip this
is a very very big question that we have
entertained again and again on the
channel uh throughout season one but
yeah especially this season
uh does he use protection is it does he
seek consent he's 50 he's 50. we have
not yet though done a full analysis
of grogu's motivations his his character
alignment
like we have seen star wars moral
alignment charts before
but where would grogu land on one of
those now right after season one a few
observers did try to place the child on
this
grid you know the one lawful good lawful
evil you know on on a scale of legality
to chaos
and a scale of good to evil lawful
mothful
waffle moffle is what a moff gideon is
awful waffle is a terrible other thing
awful waffle okay but clearly i think we
can all agree that the child is at the
very least an
agent of chaos he's gonna lean towards
the right side of that chart and it was
even more true in season two
but uh our question is now what
direction is that chaos aimed
towards good or toward evil well let's
look back at all the evidence we have
seen throughout
these two seasons and let's start philip
with season one so grogu began
as anyone begins true neutral before we
really learn what they're doing as far
as we know
he might have done stuff before in that
egg he might have gotten
inside that egg there's just a lot of
dead birds in that egg what's that smell
under grogoo's bed
don't look in there nothing he was just
fully inactive neither good nor bad
neither lawful nor
chaotic but he was just there but then
he eats a live frog that's the first
thing that people were like
what though yeah i remember feeling very
uncomfortable in that moment because we
didn't he was so
cute still and we were like yeah he's
kind of a frog himself
well he's a carnivore and uh to many
vegans that makes you a type of evil now
i would say that slit him over to
at least chaotic neutral but no moral
judgment to be made there he's just a
hungry baby
however he does save mando by using the
force to slay the mud horn
and that was grogo's first real choice
that we saw in the show and you could
argue it both ways right
you could say it's a lawful good because
he is saving another life at the expense
of his own energy and he's acting in
self-defense
against a dangerous predator which i
would say uh star wars common law is a
form of stand your ground that's a law
in the florida section of the galaxy
uh-huh arvalo 7 is very florida there's
ranchers
who are hurting weird animals that he
shouldn't be hurting but also
you know this was a mama mud horn just
protecting her
egg which the jawas only wanted so they
could eat it that was pretty mean
so the kill may have been lawful and
duty-fold in order to protect
the life of himself and his caretaker
but it was arguably a bit cruel
like uh groho did not know the context i
think at the end of the day we can call
this uh
lawful neutral choice that at least
slides grogoo back toward the true
neutral square
now throughout the season grogu
continues lots of baby like he
snatches that spherical knob off the
control stick nothing big here
maybe making him a bit more chaotic
neutral though you're making a moral
judgment on a baby plane with a toy
no moral judgment just izzy is that
lawful or is that chaotic and babies
in their nature are chaotic but then
then philip we learned that verna
herzog's client character was
okay with grogu being killed that's a
big deal because
even the antagonist pain for his capture
considers it a viable outcome
for the child to be disposed of what
does that tell us that tells us that at
least views this child is dangerous
and i think that would put grogu firmly
in the category of chaotic neutral he's
already there but he's there
remind me was the client technically
trying to get grogu for moff giddy he
was
but there's still a lot of unanswered
questions there right if the client
would have been okay with grogu dying
that goes right up against moff gideon's
right to harvest uh blood from him
right so they aren't totally on the same
page yeah it could very much be like
all right i'll bring him to you dead or
alive he's like i said alive
exactly exactly that's it there's a lot
there from those first three episodes
that we have to go back and look at
you know the show is not done with those
mysteries and the same goes for
what we assumed to be a bounty hunter
that the client hired the assassin of
episode four on that farm
village where he had baby yoda grogu in
his
crosshairs what does it tell us that all
these people want the kid
killed it's like he's a wmd like a kind
of
chaotic neutral force that in the wrong
hands
could be devastating let's think that
real quick because
i think that's a huge huge accusation
you're making against a baby but
also i've seen babies do some dark
i've been one
but you got to think like most people in
the galaxy because
they don't have from what understand
they don't have normal internet even
they have 1970s technology in the galaxy
they don't know yet that the jedi
were integral in defeating the empire
most people don't know that the emperor
is a sith or a for
horse practitioner in their eyes he was
just a nice bureaucrat who was almost
assassinated
by these wizards and he was so
successful spreading that propaganda we
saw this a bit in clone wars right the
the final season of clone wars
the average street level martez sister
thinks the jedi are these corrupt
trouble-bringing people so that's the
little people know
of the jedi to begin with i i do think
it is a little weird that
so few people knew of the jedi's
existence despite luke skywalker
famously blowing up the death star
thanks to just trusting his sorceress
realistically
it probably very quickly became a
religious myth
we're absolutely right and it's a very
important context to keep in mind when
it comes to how people look at uh grogu
but then there's a big
turning point this is really when people
first started talking about it that
moment he forced chokes cara dune
in season one in fairness to grosgu he
believed cara was harming mando in that
moment and he was acting out of defense
for his friend
like the mudhorn just like the mudhorn
he was flashing back to that moment the
fact that he resorted though to a move
like force choking is a bit alarming
it's specific
that was like vader's go-to move we did
a big question episode about that
now many argue that luke also
force-choked gamorean guards outside
jabba's palace sure sure but i would
counter argue that in return of the jedi
luke was moving toward a place of shared
perspective with his father
that he was forced to you know cruelly
detached from his friends in the fleet
in the final battle
luke was getting a little dark in that
movie and was part of it
so yeah it's a dark specific move makes
me a little worried that someone taught
him to do that
now the kid can lift a mud horn
how much can carrot dune weigh he could
be like
move aside yeah he could just lightly
shove her back a little bit he can he
can move her arm their arm wrestling
just kind of move it off
she could have done one of those but she
choked he went for the windpipe that
goes to show he wasn't thinking clearly
that famously would uh would go with a
jedi who is headed on the wrong path
if he's letting emotion control
so i think we can call grogu's force
choke lawful evil
he was acting and what he thought was
self-defense a duty to
his his caretaker that is a lawful
instinct but
it is evil to think that you need to use
deadly force to take care of that that
brings us to the end of season one where
groga pretty much redeems himself he uh
force heals grief karga he didn't need
to do that
and then he uses the force to repel the
fire from the flamethrowers
in in the town that fire block did blow
back that flame trooper but it was in
pure self-defense
it was lawful it was good these were
altruistic choices so i think
that kind of brings this full circle
back to true neutral where we started
sorry but season two is really the
reason we're having this conversation
obviously changes the game uh it swings
grogu
back at least into the agent of chaos
the chaotic column
in chapter nine i don't even want the
frog on it no we gotta talk about the
eggs
because he also eats these spider eggs
and this is which is that's fair spider
eggs are might be fair
they're cold it's like a nice yummy
spidery popsicle have you had spider egg
have you had it oh you are gonna it's
superb
now the thing with the frog eggs is he
was explicitly told not to
and he knew what they meant to that frog
mom
uh because he sneakily crept around the
razor crest he looked around the corner
he knew what he was doing was messed up
eric
had those eggs been spermed it decides
everything
okay they've been sperminated then those
are
living creatures in there if life begins
at egg but if those are
unspermed eggs then the what's good for
the game fertilized
fertilized is the word for it that was
burped that's a
thing for manure gross the
you are right you are right grogu is not
a perpetrator of genocide however
he kind of did go up to a woman and
scrape eggs out of
her body and eat them don't use the word
scraped that's what he did
and he slurped them down they were in a
jar
like they are for many women who are
saving it for later in their career
and then also really quick this is also
traumatic for me because i think you
know this but not everyone does
when i was in fifth grade we spent like
a big time learning about
how to make eggs for some reason
everyone had to practice like bring eggs
in
from home and we were gonna make a whole
egg meal for the whole class
and we all brought in our store-bought
eggs and one little
b word dina lived on an actual farm and
she was like i'm bringing a natural egg
or whatever and it was from the farm and
hers was the only brown one ours was all
white
and then the teacher was like oh let's
this one's extra special we all felt
lame as hell
and we make this big pot she had this
giant pan for 40 kids
to eat eggs and then it's like and then
let's put dina's egg on it and she
cracked it over it
and a dead baby chicken fell out onto it
and it had like blood in the in the egg
and it spoiled the entire pot of all the
eggs
we had to throw the whole thing out but
we also just saw a little corpse land
we all screamed i was gonna say did the
kids scream because of course kids are
really good at screaming
uh very quickly uh and we had a pizza
party instead
pizza time oh yeah oh that that
definitely worked but that would know
that was really traumatizing but that is
how i learned that we normally eat
unfertilized eggs if an egg is
fertilized it is very different that's
why you don't sperminate an egg
yeah but either way philip the fact that
grogu was sneaking around while everyone
else was sleeping and then way to do it
show like anything that you have to do
at night while everyone else is sleeping
you have to make sure people are
sleeping to do it
is evil you grew up in that kind of
household so i believe that i just
remembered though i do have to correct
myself
they had not been sperminated yet that
was the whole point of getting them to
that
to the other planet because that guy was
gonna do his business
all over that jar yeah and he did he did
we saw the other side of it for sure
and not only that philip he kept doing
it after mando told him
stop yeah yeah he kept to aftermath like
stop doing it it's already fertilized
he's like
i can't they can never be too fertilized
grogu grogu
kept eating the eggs and uh and then
even at that weird
hot spring in the middle of the ice cave
he went over to these ice spider eggs
that endangered all of them
yeah you could say eating the ice
spiders was uh chaotic neutral but
eating those frog eggs was chaotic evil
that's your joker dark knight chaotic
that's a
leap but yes but that's what people
normally put in that square
joker is chaotic now it gets scarier in
chapter 13 when ahsokitano comes into
the show and she looks at that kid and
she's like
nope not she gave it a shot but then she
saw that grogu
and mando had this connection the same
way that anakin had personal connections
making him vulnerable making him
fearful that he could lose something and
that is not the jedi way
and suddenly ahsoka cares about the jedi
way despite
you know years and years of being
divorced from it i'll give though it's
also she's
analyzing his fear she can just right
this child has a lot of fear and she
knows that that's dangerous whether or
not it's against the whole and she saw
it firsthand with anakin despite
whatever she may feel about the jedi she
knows that they were dead right with
their reluctance to
train anakin you know but even more
interesting to me philip was the fact
that ahsoka had no idea who grogu was
until she read his mind even though
grogu is only five years older than her
they would have trained at the temple
around the same time that tells us that
the jedi council was so freaked out by
this kid
that they made sure grogu was hidden
away from all the other young ladies
i think out of fear that his impulses
were too powerful to control he had to
get special one-on-one time with the
teachers
do we think that it's because play the
clip
it's off the charts i highly doubt we'll
find a donor with a higher m count
though that's part of it it's
interesting because the
highest midichlorian count we know of
was uh anakin right 20 000 which was
higher than master yoda himself
which astonished obi-wan and qui-gon
jinn
even though qui-gon jinn was a master at
the time so that made it sound like
there was no one who had a higher m
count than anakin
at that time of phantom menace i'm
thinking grogu
and we've we have done and will do other
videos on this on the channel i think
grogu
was with the jedi order before anakin
was
and that is why when they saw anakin at
age nine they're like
uh no like we already got one homer but
despite her fears for his future his
potential
grogu is not there yet but i so i would
say philip that fear makes him a chaotic
neutral
a chaos being he is too powerful to
control we don't know what direction
he's going to go in yet right
the potential uh to be evil does not
make you evil
but then we see in chapter 14 when grogu
is captured he thrashes around those
stormtroopers
but specifically again he force chokes
one of them that is a deliberate
specific move babies don't have an
instinct to choke well and then he was
like you like that don't you
i was like what they didn't need to put
that in yeah why did they put that in
the subtitle
yeah this is first words on the show
what a weird first word now it's a
really really dark moment and it's
underlined by the fact that
you know another guard tries to
intervene and moth getting's like no no
no let him finish
he enjoys this darkness coming out of
the child this
is a chaotic evil act and that is
classic
uh you know sith energy not that i'm off
getting is but
wanting to see a force user to like give
in to that and encouraging them to get
into that we
i mean that's probably your best
argument use your aggressive feelings
boy let the heat flow
uh the editors had to uh cut out a
section there
uh where eric and i reminisce about the
different people that we know who do
pull her
that'll be in the future episode that's
why you gotta keep watching every week
it might be this week you never know
um but uh the sum total of everything we
know about grogu's actions
on this show is that he is really on the
border between chaotic neutral
and chaotic evil it's the big question
of the show
actually where you know we think it's
all about getting
grogu to his kind to be taken care of
and it actually is about is grogu
good for the galaxy or bad for the
galaxy
yeah you know you know why because
that's a way
to mirror the mandalorian as he's been
portrayed on this show
which is very much the cowboy and the
cowboy is famously
can can be you know lawful evil chaotic
good like cowboys are famously on
the spectrum of uh good table
and i think that this show really likes
to play this this western element there
of
complex morality and especially where it
combines with eastern philosophies we
saw that very much in the episode where
you meet ahsoka
that also has like the the jedi order is
very you know close to the religious
order and like buddhist and whatnot
and they interpret these things in a
more energy-based way
and mando's very much like look i have a
list i have things i have to do and i do
have
are a very particular set of skills and
those two
philosophies have a lot to do with like
general energies
versus the rules and both of these
characters exist
on that spectrum and constantly kind of
switch over
yeah i think uh if we could position
mando somewhere he would probably be in
the category of a lawful neutral
you know it's like nativillian on
firefly right like they wear the black
cat they wear the white hat
uh and they go back and forth but they
have a code
man's got to have a code awesome and i
think even though
in this uh star wars universe whoever's
in charge the laws change a lot in this
post imperial age when the new
republic's trying to get started
mando's normally within the confines of
the law and his own code he's pretty
sacred to that
and he sticks to that by he's guided by
this sense of duty so that makes him a
lawful figure but he's neutral in his
way he plays on that i have a question
is lawful contextual to
like where you are basically i mean
nazis yeah a nazi is just following
orders right i mean famously
uh darth vader is used as an example of
lawful evil
uh because he is following the laws of
his but he's using
laws and he's using the established
order
to justify his villainy so that's kind
of where it is
if you're within the establishment
you're a lawful figure
i'll leave this this question on you
then in general
i think that jedi in general where do
they fall
as a group there's a lot of debate over
this but
i would call them a lawful neutral
they're kind of like these picard
figures right and the height of the the
jedi order right they only intervene
in things where they're trying to
preserve the peace
but they do let a lot of bad things
happen
to stick to that code but while before
order 66 the jedi
are very much part of the establishment
they're right at the seat of power
um so by that nature they are absolutely
lawful yoda on the other side of it is
more of a neutral character
yes yeah so let us know in the comments
this guy
chaotic good chaotic evil adorable
that can be all nine categories for sure
also
deeper question here are we saying by
these definitions are
all babies chaotic evil i was gonna ask
you that i was like i
i don't want to bring this up on camera
because i
there are kids watching our show
sometimes but i think you're saying kids
are evil
period they're at least chaotic we can
say they're chaotic they're either
chaotic neutral some people say they're
chaotic good
some people say the chaotic evil chaotic
a lot of work
wow all right we got to move on and we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode starting with our
friends at betterhelp this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp is there
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals i know philip and i
have both felt that way before
very much uh we have felt that way
ourselves we might know someone in your
life who's not really doing great right
now
and every once in a while that someone
is us
well better help is great it assesses
your needs and matches you with
your own licensed professional therapist
to start communicating
in under 48 hours now it is not a crisis
line it's not self-help it is just
professional counseling
done securely online and if you feel
like you are in crisis let's put a
link down in the description where there
are places you can call if it's urgent
uh and you kind of need to talk to
somebody right now
this is a little bit about uh
maintenance that you would do on your
car
you're just doing it on yourself yeah
it's it's proactive mental health you
know because it's something that we have
to continually work on not just when
things are bad you know and there is a
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available in a lot of
areas yeah well
this service is available worldwide you
can log
in anytime send a message to your
counselor you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions no sitting in an
uncomfortable waiting room which a lot
of us can't really leave our homes right
now so this is
a way you can still get the help you
need my therapist and i switched to
completely uh video based and honestly i
have no intention to
ever go back to easier i just like it so
in the middle of my day i get to just
kind of have my fast
yeah absolutely now better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available twitter help wants you to
start living a happier life today
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted
daily visit betterhelp.com bigquestion
that is betterhelp.combigquestion
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional ding
eric what is our next sponsor oh uh
thank you for phrasing it in the form of
a question because our next sponsor
is jeopardy how has this should be the
first time that big question is
sponsored by jeopardy
ah it took too long well i want to tell
you about
play show jeopardy it's a new jeopardy
game available on playstation
xbox and windows play show jeopardy lets
you test your knowledge using
actual episodes of jeopardy the game
combines your console and your mobile
device so you can buzz and speak your
answers
just like if you were on the show philip
and i have had friends who have been on
the show before
none of them have won none of them have
won but now we can feel like we were
them and we can exist on the show
and do even worse than they did probably
i also submitted to be on kids jeopardy
when i was a kid it was called jeff oh
when you're an adult
philip kicked their ass we love stuff
like this we both love pub trivia our
channels based on trivia
absolutely and uh we had a blast playing
this game it's a great game
for you to play with your roommates or
your family members you can talk trash
to your dad when he blows all of his
earnings on a daily double
because he forgets the capital of
wisconsin racine
kenosha no it's madison you can play by
yourself
as i will probably have to do or uh with
up to three total players and play
across different areas and
additional dlc packs with favorites like
teen tournament
road to the all-stars and all-stars
captain's classics you don't ever feel
smarter than playing against teens in
jeopardy
it is mwah you i mean you don't win but
you do
you do better than you would have done
it's like this is my kind of jeopardy
bubble gum question now actually the
game is 20 off on playstation until
january 19th
so you have time get on it just go to
playshowtv.com to start playing
play show jeopardy right now that's
playshowtv.com
well now it comes to time for a bite
size question that phillip is going to
chew
all up for you and spit in your mouth
are you ready phillip
[Music]
hmm
uh all right the question is what is the
significance
of lightsaber colors i'm glad you asked
this because
i put a lot of thought into the color
choices that make new rockstars videos
and stuff and no one ever thinks to ask
that
just like lightsabers the blue dungeon
is powered by kyber crystals
that's why i'm getting irradiated yeah
exactly oh my god
it's experimented though when those
crystals when copper crystals are first
mined they actually
have no color a lot of people think that
it's some sort of like rainbow kyber
crystal field
but no there's no color to them but it's
when they bond with a jedi
who chooses them that they actually take
on a color kind of like a mood ring
kind of like a bk kids mug it's like uh
i think the the crystal starts to
deteriorate until there's one where it's
a crystal's like yes this one and then
it stays attacked and it turns to color
yeah it used to be
back in uh the legends days that the
crystal kind of knew
the role of the jedi yeah i was bonding
with and it was kind of like this one's
a policeman
let's make it you know like like this
one's a farmer
it's like you've made 12 farmers look we
got a lot of greens
to print but uh it since it made more
sense where now it doesn't
guess what your role is or you have to
have a role before you do it now it's
based on your spiritual alignment which
makes
a lot more sense honestly so that makes
sense also when most people are
generally blue obi-wan lightsaber that's
luke skywalker
the anakin's with blue kiarimundi ahsoka
tano
during clone wars leia even titan now we
know this during her training that's a
blue one
ben solo during his training i mean it
kind of you'd be it'd be fine for you to
think that blue is
the default color but again no it's more
their spiritual alignment
that is righteousness in and bravery
tends to be kind of a default
alignment for jedi uh especially when
they're being
uh trained in the extended universe that
was uh guardian role which is yeah the
jedi guardian yeah but that's
sadly no longer the case the second most
common you can probably guess it right
green yeah green second most common but
it's usually associated with the wiser
ones yeah i kind of think that they kind
of were like what color deoda
let's make green mean wise but also you
know qui-gon who i i was always a bit
the biggest fan of because of his like
mellow wisdom
kit fisto the best name of any porn star
quinlan boss also a great porn star name
yeah exactly eric boss fantastic horns
are under 70s and luke in
jedi that um tends to be about having
and we talked you were talking about
this earlier
having arrived at a state of harmony
it's a cooperation
goodwill in the eu is the consular
it's like there's two ways an old man
can get grumpy and hilarious
we're just kind of like mellow and he
kind of like knows everything's cool and
green is mellow baby yeah once you have
a green lightsaber it's kind of like
kids will follow you around and be like
an old man's telling a story
i murdered villages the kids are like no
no let us go and it's like don't you go
nowhere
you listen to my stories we've seen red
lightsabers quite a bit actually and so
you do know that sith warriors get red
lightsabers darth vader famously
sidious darth maul taranis kylo ren but
kylo ren's is kind of i
i would say that one's like works
differently so it's it's not clear that
it it could have been like kind of his
little
i feel so bad when i make fun of him but
he you know he's like cosplaying as
vader
it feels like he might have been able to
enter a color hex code on his hilt
and like make it or like the way like a
twitch guy like will put like different
colors in his background or whatever
because i can make all three of them
different if you want yeah his plasma
is not well shaped which i think would
say more about the the magnetic
field generator on the hilt rather than
the plasma itself it just seems like
it's more like a wispy like yeah
it's kind of currently on fire but yeah
he is uh he would have had to make that
on his
own kylo ren is like if a teenager says
like you want to come over to my house
and see the gun i made
no he turns around there's a hole blown
out of the back there's
candy in there bane um who else has has
read
ventress has one um and the red comes
actually from it's kind of like a
metaphorical red star wars is one of the
most uh archetypal based pieces of
pop culture ever you can learn
everything about archetypes just
watching star wars
so you would assume that red is
associated with like fury and anger and
it is
but specifically um the concept of
bleeding is
more in the the world of star wars and
of course it also
is hatred and fear and suffering and any
negative emotion
um that gets into the crystal causes it
to bleed red it's kind of the concept
there
um in the eu not the european union
in the extended universe yeah yeah yeah
actually the sith couldn't
use kyber crystals so they actually had
to make synthetic
uh kybers which were which forced them
to be red but again
once again it's just so much more
interesting when it's like bonding with
your red dark soul
uh because they had to invent new colors
they couldn't just say like well all
these different rainbow rocks were
in on ilum somewhere speaking of
inventing new colors
uh that brings us to white which totally
reminds me of the same thing
that happened on power rangers where
they made the white ranger he was
following the green ranger
the time has come to reveal your
identity
white is often this thing where it's
like little kids are like white was an
option
yeah we could add white this whole time
yeah everybody knows white is the
coolest
like it's the mystery airhead too which
is just like blueberry what a crazy
mystery tommy went missing and there was
that whole reveal like who will be the
white ranger and they slowly lifted off
the helmet and the whole time i was like
who is it going to be i thought it was
going to be another famous movie star
i was gonna be jim carrey for some
reason what do you mean
another famous movie star who in the
power rangers cast where you're like
well we've got
tiffany joe johnson she was already the
pink ranger you know they already had
all these other ones i thought they were
making it a mystery of like who is it
gonna be we have a new cast member on
the show
and it was just the guy who played tommy
do not go
in there lightsabers
so famously ahsoka wields these badass
whitesabers honestly she's like the
main reason they look so cool and it's
because she made him in this really cool
way she killed um the exquisitor who's
the sixth brother
his blade was red and she used the force
it's just
awesome she used the force to purify
them
which kind of implies taking them back
to their original kyber state
but it actually is representing ahsoka's
status and kind of her alignment
as this autonomous loner right instead
of aligning in any direction
it's like without alignment um so she's
not affiliated with jedi
or sith she's just you know a white girl
except she's not one of these light
sabers is the shoto blade
a shorter blade you see how they snuck
out
because it's a little bit shorter it's a
little bit shorter in the books ahsoka
carried
a yellow green shadow saber uh but
never in in live action because yellow
green is the only reason only in my
gatorade eric
what is the only color that after it's
like wait white was an option
that can like defeat the white one or or
counter the white one oh we gotta be
talking about the dark saber
that is a very specific scenario it's an
ancient saber that was created by
tarvisla
i was kept in the jedi temple it was
stolen by the
vizla house i have passed down through
the ages until it was taken away by maul
sabine wren finds it she gives it to
poketan moth getting has it we've seen
plenty of the dark saber but that's like
not an option for most people
there's never an option yeah there's
only one of those that's why we know
when we saw him off getting with it
we're like whoa that's like the
one dark saber there's no others oh
in physics so again there is like some
alignment here with the concepts of
lights we know that black
actually is the absence of light and we
are talking about
lightsabers so the concept of a dark
saber
is is clearly trying to represent this
connection toward the idea of
light so being without colors in these
lights it comes from the total
absorption
of visible light so that could suggest
tar vista's crystal
didn't even bother emitting light right
there was like an absence of light and
that's
just a really dark thing to happen can
you imagine you're like
all right it's going to light up your
color and it's just like mine didn't
have a color and they're like get away
from in diablo
yeah there is something creepy about
that right not only did it not
emit light not only did not reflect
light
it absorbed the light around it's like a
black hole
if it's black it must absorb light
that's how anything black when you take
it out into the daylight or any other
thing in the room
it is absorbing the light so that's what
that saber is doing that might be what
that white
glow is but it's kind of like a black
hole but what's cooler than black baby
and what was made for the black jedi oh
oh purple that is
purple mace windu's personal request
from samuel jackson that becomes star
wars canon
you might get purple yeah that's how a
lot of stuff becomes canon
it's just it was okay and there was the
concept of purple being the combination
of red and blue so the two things we
said before
so morally ambiguous and sexually but
that's kind of eu because mace windu was
not morally ambiguous
so now it's just kind of like it's a
rare color and it means
mace like yeah exactly
yellow is a color that we've seen used
by jedi temple guards
and uh ray in the in the final scene of
rise of skywalker um which is like
it's it's kind of cool in a book called
dark disciple massage ventress uh in
that used the yellow blade and in
uh the eu the old republic sentinels
would carry yellow blades too they saw
the color to like represent kind of just
practical use of the force like
like almost like construction right it's
more of a it's like a tool
rather than like uh this is my
lightsaber everybody like it but this
one is mine
mine isn't that what you said when you
proposed to your girlfriend i did yeah i
screamed at everyone else like there are
many other women like her but this one
is mine actually there's no other women
like her
congratulations again little baby thank
you eric and kelly's sitting in a tree
getting c-o-v-i-d yeah yeah but only
with each other
yeah it's because the tree had it yeah
damn tree you always they're the last
ones you suspect i don't ever want to
see it again
ever you know what i love about the
final shot of the rise of skywalker
us picking a lightsaber color that makes
the lightsaber akin to a mop
it's a great tool i'll give you that
this is
guy it's just like on the council it's
like really
yellow okay all right i would go for
nice
racing stripes
like uh play with his hot wheels yeah
and it's like somebody's brother-in-law
they got to be on the jedi council
it's like him yeah yeah yeah well he had
the lowest
m count we've ever seen ah i have a
homer on it
had some uh i had a yellow lightsaber in
some stories but also
uh sometimes orange and others yeah i
remember jedi power battles he was the
one who had an orange one i'm like who's
that orange one
i think plokun did turn it blue though
in in canon stories there's a orange
lightsaber in um jedi fallen order uh
yeah calcastus gets an orange one that
we don't know anything about why it's
orange why that's important
yeah we just need an orange one in it
delicious in the morning
it's uh delicious as a creamsicle and
that's the significance of the colors of
the jedi who asked this bite-sized
question
i love you eric what is the reason for
everything
toys toys toys you get a toy and you get
a toy
it's because the more variations the
more you can sell
reminder baby you had a merch available
and in our shirts and it is in multiple
colors
represent your alignment well thank you
for answering that philip
we'd love to learn how the corporate
merchandise
sales market is controlling our lives
and our destinies
we have time for one final box scraps
question oh
and we have uh pointed our ooh what's
this
the box of scraps theme song
[Music]
is it the homer's thinking music right
[Laughter]
[Music]
well we have pointed our judgmental geez
at
grogu but uh speaking on this question
of
evil have you ever felt
evil evil evil
[Music]
i feel like you've thought i was evil at
multiple times i thought i
i still think i might be evil i'm
waiting to find out
i've never done anything wrong set those
fires i said
you mentioned a script you were writing
about baby hitler
i wrote a script that started with the
baby hitler concept it became a
terminator thing
uh called evil blonde mail it was based
on a podcast i used to do called the
evil blonde kid podcast
where it was kind of like a narrative uh
anecdotal podcast where i would tell
stories
about the kid from seventh heaven he
just like really put him in his place
every week
look what he did this week yeah exactly
david gallagher or whatever his name is
what he did this week
get this get this um
no uh yeah yeah so it was like telling
stories from my youth from my past
where i felt like i was the bad guy of
that story it was kind of like a
confessional type thing
it was because you know in media it's
often like oh they're the malfoy that's
the evil one or the johnny and karate
kid he's the jerk you know
there's just you know it goes back to
the hitler aryan thing of a lot of them
were blonde and they were all evil
yeah i did this podcast i i was kind of
proud of it especially really what it
the best thing that came out of it was
that script i kind of stopped the
podcast after that point because i ran
out of stories to tell that weren't like
humiliating to myself or people that i
knew
well i kind of remember this too that
like not a lot of time would pass and
you'd have to take an episode down
like like yeah again because i'm like oh
this is bad
like someone's gonna find this uh yeah
so i think it's all taken down now
though you may be able to find it
somewhere
so years later this is an ex-girlfriend
of mine i
told her about this podcast and i was
like oh yeah you should listen to it
because she's like yeah i want to see
the stuff that you've made uh she didn't
talk to me for a couple days and then we
went and got dinner that friday
and she was kind of quiet during the
dinner and uh i had mentioned i'm like
oh did you listen to the evil blonde kid
you knew immediately yeah and she goes
yeah
i listen to all of them you aren't still
like that
are you like it really changed her
opinion of me
and then she's like and you're not gonna
do a podcast episode about me
are you no i'll talk about you in a
future podcast yeah i'll talk about you
in uh in big question in the future i
won't mention you by name though
uh no but like yeah i realized i'm like
oh this isn't like a good
thing i've been putting this on social
media and people were judging me for
this
and and kelly has not listened to it and
she never will she'll not be alive
she can take back that ring eric you're
creating too much fomo for something
that people probably can't go find give
us a clear quick story
of an evil blonde kid story what did you
do though so wrong
that made this girl give up dating i
think the last one i did was like a
parody of house of cards where it was
like me recounting my political
machiavellian uh conniving tricks where
i was like student council president in
eighth grade
uh and it was my account my confession
of how i
sabotaged uh a senator in student
council
um because he was he was gonna be like a
rival to me
and i had a senate in eighth grade well
each grade
got to send two representatives or
something and he
was uh a representative and he fell
below
a a b average and i
knew about it and i had him removed from
student council
because he was like a thorn in my side
or something horrible
i still can't believe that you had a
senator with representatives as your
student council
my student council was a gang that you
had to get beaten into by the teachers
you had to fight a teacher to get into
the student council again
our viewers are learning the difference
between north florida and south exactly
you have to beat your way into the
student council and you get pregnant and
give birth at prom
and technically i'm still in the city
council you're in it for life
how about you philip have you ever felt
like the the bad guy in the narrative
yeah i mean if that's the thing you're
measuring it by then
then yes because of that south florida
thing honestly because
yeah i don't even remember like i was a
good kid but i i grew up in a really bad
area and i didn't know it was a bad area
until you know my older siblings were
doing bad stuff
and when it started to become clear that
they were trying to like groom me to
you know take over the family business a
little bit if you will and remember they
like
cut two slits into my eyebrow and shave
my head and
bought me all this this ghetto of
clothes but i was still like i love
computers
but whatever but then there was a
stretch there where i remember it was
i remember a summer specifically like i
was the kid that i would go to summer
school because we didn't have um
babysitters or daycare whatever
but i would like like it because i would
like take more computer classes and
stuff
but um one day i'll be a youtuber in the
teacher thought i was an idiot because
that wasn't a word yet
um and uh uh but i remember during that
time it was really confusing for me
because
my brother and was was you know he was
getting a lot of trouble but he was also
it was like really cool honestly and he
wasn't a gang at the time and so i
started to i had slits in my eyebrows
and i started to try to like mimic that
behavior but like the child-like version
of that
so it was like the ideas of what i
thought were bad which 100
i did not get from anything other than
the movie problem child it was like
a phone yeah exactly so i dyed my hair
bright red
um i put on blue freckles
and i rolled a giant ball over the woman
that was going to marry me that was from
child too
you flattened her nose yeah exactly no
but um and she has to fix the next day
during that time though i was trying to
be bad and i can
think of like oh i can think of three
things that i did during that time
one was i i remember like i was like you
know
i think maybe i was even like skipping
class or i was definitely walking
through you know like when you're when
you're little you're not supposed to
like roam the school
and this is like after school i think i
was just like waiting to get picked up
or something so i would roam the school
and remember i found a classroom where
on the chalkboard
some student had drawn this amazing
mural and chalk of ariel from the little
mermaid
and it was just like and i just erased
the whole thing oh that's so deep
and uh the next name this is mark's uh
she was my previous teacher
she must have seen me do it or something
she called me and dropping she's like
why did you do that that was really mean
and i was like i don't know
it's fun to do bad things yeah it's fun
to do bad things um
uh that i thought rock music was bad to
the bone and jingle bell rock and those
were my
two of jingle bells
it had rock in the name and i thought it
was so cool the
next thing i did is actually pretty bad
so i got used to walking home
uh eventually and one day i just got in
my head that i was gonna do something
really bad
so i picked up a rock and i threw it
through a window in my apartment complex
and i just broke their window
and here oh god i still feel really bad
about this because
this is like the wheat i don't know if
it's my ocd
or what or or just weird sense of
completion
every time they fix the window i would
break it again oh no they would repair
the window and i was like not on my
watch and i'm throwing rock through the
window again this is a bad neighborhood
and i did it like three or four times
like i kept breaking that window
god those people it was probably a sweet
old lady who's just yeah
or they like it probably was like a hate
crime and i didn't know because the food
who lived there or something oh no
the only other thing that i did that i i
don't feel guilty about is like i
started to
look into like porn and see like oh
that's what i could do but
you couldn't find it easily on the
internet at the time so i i looked i
found my brother's stash
and then i would uh call a friend over
and we would look at it
um and then i did go looking for it on
the internet and you couldn't find it at
the time but the one thing i was able to
find
uh i this i i perfectly remember even
what it looked like and because i
printed it out in black and white on my
printer
was a a nudie picture of blossom
my ambialic it was clay it must have
been photoshopped like the photoshop
yeah yeah
yeah but i couldn't tell the difference
and i was like holy crap blossom i got
one of her yeah whoa um she's missing a
finger in real life
but anyway uh and i printed it out and
then
for some reason i and i put in my
backpack to show kids at school
and then i felt so guilty about having
that in my backpack that on my walk to
school
i jammed it in somebody's like power
meter box
like instead yeah it was the person
whose window you broke
yeah actually that was my alex apartment
that you were
she was just like what is going on
and then uh whatever it was messed me up
bad enough that at one point i was like
i swore off porn
and i went back to my um my brother's
stash of porn magazines
and i cr i put white out bikinis on
every single lady
that is evil your brother was like oh my
god what a psychopath
yeah ew there's something
gross that would be freaking crazy
you're talking about someone spermed all
of
the dessert is my maggie
not the girl named mark that's what he
calls his magazine so i won't fertilize
my maggie
that's what i want to know who did a
farmer brings his daughter to the town
center
she's like pregnant and say who
fertilized my maggie and this
cracks are open into an egg pan
he's a farmer and he only knows farmer
term so it's like he's like a
chicken well i may not be a city chicken
look i'm a simple southern chicken
somebody fertilize my daughter he's
gonna pay for that egg
can can i just say real quick uh no
anxiety has ever been higher for
a young man of a certain age than
waiting for his black and white
internet porn to be printed out from the
family computer come on hurry
hurry up it's so loud it's like so it's
louder than usual
matrix yeah just like one line at a time
and it's like
three lines for the nipple really come
on yeah
yeah then it's like halfway up and it
freezes
your heart stops like come on i'm done
with it i'm good i'm good i'm good
well that's it for this episode of big
question we went places
we were a dr seuss book right now oh the
places you'll blow
uh well philip happy new year again
thanks for joining me this episode we're
going to happy new year
previously i did at the beginning of the
episode three hours ago
it was a long time ago yeah um well uh
we have an exciting exciting
new year it sounds like movies are back
on in 2021 folks
so we got a lot in store for you here at
new york stars
speaking of real quick this is huge
uh more details in the announcement
video but
eric and tommy and me are
working out nerd style look at those
muscles that that are underway yeah we
pre-shot this episode so
i may be thinner now in the video
yesterday's video
just a little bit it's a it's something
that we're taking a little bit of risk
on but we really appreciate it if you go
watch those episodes and enjoy them and
get to know what it's like uh when the
rest of our bodies get involved
yeah and and that weird feeling of
seeing me have legs
i have them yeah that's weird uh well
you can follow phillip at philip molina
follow me at ea boss make sure to follow
new rockstars on all socials and send us
your big questions using that
big question be sure to subscribe to our
podcast feed version of this
and give us a nice rating and review
that helps people see it and hear it you
know
uh subscribe to rockstars of course here
on youtube be sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications when our stuff comes out
and uh we will see you next week happy
new year everybody
if it was your window i'm so sorry i'll
pay
you should apologize to me and be alec
you know it was her she was trying to
record that video of herself dancing in
her bedroom and a rock keeps flying
well she was going to go open the window
and it smashed and then she caught her
finger on and lost her finger did she
really lose a finger
man bialik is missing a finger we're
looking it up see you
guys later
[Music]
you